hey everybody John Luke and Alessandra
here we are in West Virginia which of
course means we just play it fallout 76
and we're at the Greenbrier resort which
is a an extremely ritzy and like you
know super gaudy it's very 50s isn't
completely appropriate for the fallout
setting there's actually a bunker
underneath this resort and in fact it's
actually in the game yep
[Music]
yeah we got our hands on with three
hours fault 76 hours I feel like I
finally understand what this game is
it's Fallout 4 but with other people
basically basically a it's a good way of
describing it some a lot of ways it's
sort of like a super like a it's more of
a souped-up version of like the survivor
mode from fallout 4 yeah in some ways
and not like there are survival
mechanics because they're not as
in-depth as like the survival mode you
have to pay attention to you know like
your water and go and stuff like that
but it's mmm it never felt like too much
of a hassle I think from you're
concerned about that kind of thing it's
not like hardcore survival it's like a
you know survival light I guess but
still like you know you need to keep
track of like how your characters are
doing making sure you don't catch a case
of red worms which is a new thing I
couldn't figure how to get rid of that
just kind of went away well I'm just
like radiation like you know when you
catch like these sort of diseases or
other like ailments like it'll SAP your
sort of like player like a stamina and
all that uh we noticed that a you know
your AP meter which handles like which
is your action points was handles like
bats and like sprinting it'll take a
deduction when you sort of uh you know
catch it like something
everyone's probably wondering what the
structure of this game was like and
there's the introduction in the vaults
and where they kind of you know it's
Proclamation day and they have like
these little like booths you go up to
and they're like here grab your you know
stimpacks grab your camp grab your
backpack and then they kind of push you
out and from then on it's super free
from you there is a basic story that
they're kind of presenting to you you're
trying to find the overseer and so you
kind of go to this like one town area
and then you find holotape that you put
in and overseer is like oh I'm now over
here and that sort of the through line
is that you are basically trying to
discover what happened to the overseer
and there are different they have kind
of visited every area within West
Virginia that you can kind of like
explore and that's primarily how the
story is told through the politics
yeah and that initial quest were you
know you're sort of following in the
footsteps of the overseer is actually
where you sort of it does serve as like
a sort of extended tutorial it does
because a sort of like when you when you
feel like you're about to find the
overseer you actually discover like
maybe a cache of supplies and that
teaches you how to you know craft and
like a you know armor or weapons and
like even scrap stuff totally when you
play this game I would recommend
deadlies doing that at the beginning
yeah because otherwise the game is very
just sort of lets you go off like you
don't have to do that stuff but you
might be a little confused as to what to
actually you because the game throws a
lot of systems at you rent um it was a
bit overwhelming actually because you
know I felt that we sort of got out of
the vault really quickly like it seemed
like we were sort of being pushed right
we also had three hours so there's sort
of this like oh we have to see yeah I've
got to see everything we got to do
everything but uh I do feel that those
sort of early like you know moments in
the quest you know where you're trying
to you know find the overseer did allow
for for one moments of like you know for
us to sort of explore like the
surrounding areas of the towns we got to
visit right and also we encountered sort
of these moments of story like you know
the survivor stories from these
characters right which are sort of a
sidequest basic
yeah but also it allows for you know the
game to sort of like introduce those
sort of narrative moments because the
big thing for this game compared to the
other ones is that they sort of toned
down lighter than the core narrative
that you would find and pull out three
or four right so it's it doesn't I feels
like it's a much smaller like scale yes
terms of the story like it's not you got
to find your son you got to find your
dad you got a you know it's you got to
find the overseer yeah it doesn't feel
like the quest is necessarily gonna be
this grand a big world changing event
but everything about the game feels more
personal like personal stories and it's
interesting how we were talking with the
devs about and they were kind of saying
this that even though the game is a
multiplayer game and very much a social
game in that aspect the world feels very
empty and like a ghost town because
everyone's dead and it actually gave
this really kind of creepy sad vibe to
it that I really dug yeah he called it
the loneliest Fallout loneliest Fallout
game for you and all your friends but on
the inverse of that uh you know this is
also the most social fallout game right
you'll play cuz there is voice chat like
in the game
Doug yeah it's proximity-based so you
have to be within a party and you know
yeah you have to be close enough to
other players and you know you'll hear
them and of course if you encounter a
jerk or whatever you can still mute them
and you know yeah so that was that's the
other thing is that we were all in like
a party from the get-go and but you can
immediately be like our guys piece I'm
gonna go do my own thing and you can
just ignore your party completely and do
all those side quests and the story
stuff and for the most part all that
stuff feels like stuff you can just do
on your own yeah he totally took did
that like during like some missions
where we just sort of trailed off and we
had to catch up to the other guys
because there was just so much stuff so
I think if you're the kind of if you're
the kind of person who's like hey I want
to play this game I don't have friends
I'm so sorry you just want to play it on
your own it it just kind of felt like
fallout 4 yeah it's like it felt like
I'm going to this town I'm you know
checking all these like cool locations
out a lot of environmental storytelling
that like three and four very heavily
leaned on is
like very prominent in this game and you
just feel like you're kind of doing your
own thing and then occasionally you run
across another person and to be honest
that didn't it didn't feel that weird
where it's like it didn't it
I think the worry is like the illusions
gonna break it was like I'm playing this
game all of a sudden oh there's another
person and they're like you know
shouting it you know whatever at you it
didn't I didn't get that vibe at all it
just felt like there's another person oh
cool I can trade with them if I want I
can you can shoot at them but it's
really easy to avoid not getting killed
by somebody by the way like they were a
bunch of devs who were like level 16
running around and they would try and
murder one was like trying to murder me
and I was like standing there my pip-boy
just getting shot at and eventually I
was like okay I'll just leave and I just
left and you can so the player
interaction feels like something that
you can choose to engage with and if you
just want to have a more traditional
fallout experience of just discovering
this this you know wasteland I think you
can absolutely have that and uh you know
the map is like you know way bigger than
the one in for as well yeah it's huge
yeah it looks great yeah yeah it's um we
encountered like a number of like varied
locations like you know we initially
went to like a small town like you know
there's sort of like a rural area then
we went to like you know sort of I liked
the area you went to is like the sort of
the top of the world
yeah it's called top of the world and I
think it's like a diner at the top of
this mountain you can go do and and kind
of traversing up there was like really
fine there's like a ski resort and but
there's no snow right there's a great
there's a great variety yeah and it all
looks really good I mean like the
there's you know trees would like fall
leaves on them there's your even fine
areas that like don't look like they
belong in a Fallout game right when you
visit the Greenbrier in or the
Greenbrier resort and visit the
Greenbrier resort which is called white
spring in the game
first off it looks exactly like this
place but they totally nailed like the
the weird yeah like all this weird decor
it's like exactly this thing isn't the
wallpaper yeah explore in this place
like a you know like on your own and it
feels like you're walking the halls and
like the shining or something it's it's
real weird it's got that eerie vibe in
the game as well yeah they totally
nailed it like I actually walked up to
the door but if you were to open you
would see us playing the game and I was
like what if I open this door what what
I couldn't actually open the nail but
that has like a lush like green lawn and
it has had a bunch of a golf course yeah
and that golf course that Golf Course
actually had a bunch of as the game
called it unruly feral ghoul Google
Google golfers who were all level like
35 yeah completely destroyed us
they were completely vicious like you
know very wealthy ghouls who you know
just totally like just wrecked our
entire bar they don't want they don't
want us level fibre roof racks hanging
out their golf course
the humor right yeah he's like that's a
great example of humor in the game where
that's a big thing about fall for a lot
of people I feel like a lot of people
were worried that like without NPCs and
without traditional dialogue are you
getting get that and you still get a lot
of it through the signage through the
holotapes through it's very passive
criminals this is much more passive and
I'd say like that's sort of the thing
people are gonna have to come to terms
with that's a lot of the storytelling in
traditional narrative stuff is far more
passive in the game but it's still there
yeah there's a there is a narrative like
you know at play you know what I mean
like story finding the overseer but uh
as we experience like the story you know
you find in game are the ones you
discover like you know from the
environment itself but also from the
story you sort of make on your own you
because you can make the character how
you want and you can sort of a focus on
this or the areas of the game that you
want to that you want to choose right
there's also sudden be said about the
experience of discovering those
narratives with other players that you
now get there was a really cool area we
went to that was like this old airplane
that got destroyed and then a bunch of
survivors had turned it into a like a
little mini town yeah and then the
survivors were all dead if we go there
and they've all been killed by like
super mutants or if we killed the
commune's and that we're exploring and
we find I find a key that's to a it says
it's to the jail seven we're like Oh
everyone's split up and go try and find
the jail cell and we found it like an
armory that looked like a jail cell but
it was and and then eventually found the
jail cell and oh there's nothing in here
but then inside was a note and the guys
like oh I hid the key to the armory in
my like flower pops and then all of a
sudden everyone split up and go look for
this flower pot and that's where the
social element comes in - exactly and it
feels like I like those are the things
that I personally love from my fallout 3
and for that environmental storytelling
and and kind of like feeling of like
discovering these like you know old
places that are kind of fallen into
decay and being able to do that with
friends is actually really cool and I
think that that's an experience that I
think a lot of people are really gonna
like
again you can still have that experience
by yourself like we've there were many
times where we just went out on our own
and you know it did seem like you know
the sort of the odds were stacked
against us cuz we encountered a lot of
sometimes like a you know sort of mobs
of like enemies like a but in general
that also felt like that would that
happen even with other people as well it
feels more just like the game is very
much sort of breaking out segments of
the world where it's like you go over
here you're gonna get really high level
enemies you go over here gonna get lower
level enemies so maybe I've better odds
with more players but it's it's still
doable it still do okay even solo and
you can actually in count you can
actually defeat rather some enemies that
are above your level like a I noticed
you were able to take down like a level
15 like a monster when you were like
level 6 yes it does scale like you know
the damage and like sort of like a sort
of the damage resistance like as well
like depending on your level right but
that doesn't happen when you're
encountering like a another player
because low 59 player is gonna you know
totally wreck you if you're local
totally by 7 if you engage with them in
a dress if you choose to engage so the
game plays like a lot like fallout 4 and
it feels like they're taking a lot of
the mechanics from for and improving and
tweaking them in a lot of ways so things
like the crafting mechanics or like very
prominent in this game you know you are
constantly like scrapping materials at
benches they're constantly like oh I
need to upgrade my you know gun like I
can operate with like scopes and mods
and you can craft you can pre much
crafting everything I feel like for the
most part I was definitely finding
weapons but it felt like crafting was
like the primary way to at least get
like some really good stuff yeah
definitely and uh you know for the first
thing is like you know it's important to
make sure you get rid of all your junk
items and like scrap everything yeah
because uh that's actually how you're
able to sort of build like some of the
more complex
items like you know how to craft new
armor craft some of the more
sophisticated weapons fix armor they
added durability back in which they
didn't have him fall for so they brought
that back and all that stuff felt felt
really good it felt natural yeah I kind
of missed a sort of weapon conditions
like from bullet forward because uh you
know I even though I sort of prefer that
sort of more traditional like you know
we're playing like experience like I
wasn't I felt like you know sort of the
lack of like you know keeping tabs on
your sort of resources and equipment was
missing from for yeah in a way that like
that feels like something that should
fit in yeah Fallout game for sure also
there's like a really good variety of
weapons oh yeah so like you know they
have pretty much everything from for
seem to be their pipe pistols like this
dish a pistol machetes and you're pretty
much using everything you can because
like you need to use pretty much
everything mmm because you the game
starts off like you're just running out
of the vault and usually like when you
leave a vault in like you know Fallout 3
or 4 you get like a gun or like a baton
or something give you anything yeah you
were like the most unprepared unprepared
like vault dweller ever to step foot set
foot and to me pull up you know world so
they had some really funny weapons as
well I got this torched pitchfork which
was like a pitchfork but like a propane
tank I was heating up the blade just
called the heated pitch for it he didn't
pitch for it looked fantastic like I
remember you looks did like a
third-person view look at the weapon and
it was like glowing and like running
tonight and yeah like the grease are out
of it and looked it just look read that
like great there were some weapons and
interesting changes that there are level
gating there's certain weapons so for
example I couldn't use a shotgun until I
got to over 5 we killed a higher level
enemy and I found a crossbow and it was
like oh sick that sounds awesome
level 15 yep can use the crossbow yet so
I can't tell you what that experience is
like what kind of missile launcher
missile launcher if you kill like say
for example if you kill like a level 50
guy who has like a Tesla gun which is
one of the things one of the high level
people were running around with you
wouldn't even be able to use it no so
it's like it seems like they're trying
to do that as a way to also gate off
maybe
player breaking the game as far as like
high-level player helping us yeah yeah
just be like here's all my awesome gear
kid go nuts like nope you still have to
level up to actually use it so that
seems like a good decision yeah
although it's a little bummer when
you're like oh I want that cool weapon
or you rather you have it you have it
you can't you can't carry it you think
you put it I guess you put it your camp
and SPL scrap it the one day one day
I'll get that you know get to use it
so combat felt good it felt a lot like
for exactly smooth that's is weird it
took some getting too used to like
because I was fighting one of the
low-level critters like a which was sort
of like a tick yeah it was like a weird
tick that you know once a taxi that sort
of fills up with blood we just do look
great and fantastic but uh how they sort
of adjusted that's to fit within like an
online world it was that it moves in
real time so it sort of becomes like
this sort of auto targeting like a
attack yeah and you see the number
percent is like constantly moving as the
the guys running around you you couldn't
just like stay and I felt like you just
like quickly turn on vats shoot and then
like quickly get out of it is yeah the
way to get around it I kind of got some
like Robocop vibes from it like it was
just except not as like accurate because
we just started out and right you can
you can't upgrade it yes saw there was a
perk card that actually let you choose
limbs shoot specific limbs so it seems
like you can upgrade vats to be a more
powerful which is cool for those who
prefer that yeah but it definitely got
taking you stood like in most cases I
prefer just like shooting mandala yeah
and uh you know going back to what
you're saying earlier I'm it does have
that sort of an amusement park vibe to
it it does even the map yeah it's sort
of designed like it's sort of it is kind
of sectioned out in some ways like you
know there's this place like you know
the sort of the rural area it uses like
nice drawings of like you know big
landmark location sort of the way you
would like a like a park or something
and that's cool yeah and it totally ties
in to sort of the social aspect cuz like
you know it's kind of weird going to an
amusement park by yourself like you know
you'd rather maybe stainless like Walt
let's all go meet up at the you know the
mill or something and then go do this
question let's do that and there were I
think the other thing people are curious
about is if you can do everything solo
and so I feel like again the main story
and sort of explore you can do solo
there are however a couple of things
that were clearly designed for multiple
people right the first was these of
so that was just kind of randomly pop up
there is one that was like oh there's a
bunch of Google's like come over here
and you know kill these ghouls now that
one you might not need a party because I
think the idea is that other players
will just flock to that and you can just
show up and be like all right we're all
kind of working together to do this but
there are there was a specific question
we didn't do that said it was waiting
for three other people to actually like
started I think if you want to try and
accomplish everything in this game you
are at some point gonna have to have
other people on you but it seems like
you could do at least the majority of it
by yourself late and uh but some
encounters that we sort of saw during
our time was like you know finding the
Scorch beast like you know this big
massive like quietly it's like the
little moment yeah which really is like
sort of at least for me that was my list
of things I think I took away from like
fallout 4 we're just those little
moments of like going into like the
glowing sea and discovering cool like
locations like that and having those
little those little experiences that
feels like this game is built on that
and like a larger scale yeah and also we
got to see a nuke go off
they showed us what it's like to have a
nuke go off and then we ran into the
nuke totally fine I think I made me ran
into it like a little late so yeah calm
the blast but a number of players like
in our group and also the other groups
that are playing with us like you know
they immediately died I say guys it was
like running after them and they're all
just falling dead we unfortunately
couldn't see like how the sort of the
setting altered you know because the big
thing with nukes is that you know once
it drops then that area has changed like
you know the monsters and you know
become more powerful right and there's
sort of more valuable drops and
resources to find it sure quite see that
but it yeah different there's a lot of
questions you still have I mean you know
we got to start from the very beginning
of the game I first I got was level
eight so it's not like we got to really
experience what this game feels like in
the long term you don't know really like
well what are the effects of like nukes
how often do they go off and it doesn't
eventually reset like yeah those are
questions that we still don't really
know and I don't think we'll really even
know until the game fully launches and
people have like had time to spend with
it yeah this is very this is definitely
like a game that needs to be played for
the long-term cuz I feel like you can't
like get the true experience like maybe
from the first two or three hours like
you know we did absolutely we did get to
see a bit of everything which you know
for one they sort of put me at ease
because like I was a bit apprehensive
about you know some of the things about
this game but uh you know it totally
feels like a Fallout game that even with
like sort of the more toned-down aspects
of like storytelling or like you know
the world playing but it plays like a
more souped up version of Survivor my
book from fallout 4 yeah yeah so if you
were concerned that this game wasn't
gonna be a fallout game anymore I think
you can kind of put those worries to
rest it feels like fallout and if that's
what you're looking for and you want to
do it friends I think you're gonna
really good time yeah
[Applause]
okay so I think that about covers
everything we saw with fall at 76 you
feel you feel good about it I do you
know the beta is actually coming up
pretty soon right - so I'm actually
really you know interested in you know
seeing how far you know things can go
once you play for the long term good
because I feel that's where full-out 76
can really shine sure yeah I think
that's kind of the big question here I'm
surprised how much I ended up really
enjoying it it's sort of that thing
rounds like oh yeah I really like
fallout I really like running around and
playing a Fallout game and this felt
like a fallout game yeah I still sort of
missed those sort of moments of like
storytelling like role-playing like
aspect but um yeah this totally did like
rekindle a lot of those like familiar
sort of Fallout like him you know
moments of joy hundred percent yeah so
I'm I'm pretty excited for I think the
only thing at this point is just making
sure they get the game up to snuff rate
for ship if you've watched our footage
here you probably even noticed that it
is a bit frame II yeah in a lot of spots
they're very clear in stating that this
is sort of an older build and uh you
know that uh they're still working on
sort of the the bigger issues that need
to be ironed out right they were trying
to make it very clear that this is not a
final build it's a couple weeks old you
know they said that they feel very
confident that it will be 30 frames a
second when it comes in so that was kind
of the only real big thing that I felt
like all right as long as long as they
kind of get that patched up yeah for
full release I'm pretty excited for this
game alright guys so that was our
impressions on fall at 76 with the first
three hours of the game we have a lot
more videos about fall at 76 you can go
check out you guys submitted to us a
bunch of questions about the game and we
answered those so go check out that
video and we'll also have lots of pure
gameplay that you can check out as well
so stay tuned a game spot for all
coverage of fall 76
so as we stand here today we pray that
the world will know peace but if that is
not our destiny if war must come we
stand together knowing but here involved
76 our future begins
[Music]
you